- Well, you admitted that you
have the mouth of a sailor.
Has it ever gotten you into trouble?
'Cause you do a lot of kid things.
- Ooh.
It didn't occur to me, and this is a,
you know, over Christmas
everybody reminds me of this,
when I was doing, I
believe "Santa Clause 2".
- (gasps) I love that one.
- I do it in my act.
I'm not really a big fan of children.
I have them.
I like mine, kind of.
I don't like other people's children.
And when we did "Santa Clause",
it was like cats, they
wouldn't leave me alone.
I mean, I'm dressed like Santa Claus,
I looked like, we had a North Pole set,
we used real children, and in one scene
in a submarine, we're
looking, we're waiting
for the North Pole and then Air Force
is flying over the North Pole.
They had a sonar beacon.
I said, "Everybody gotta be quiet."
This is how it, and these
two kids were fighting
in the back, and the scene required,
it was late in the afternoon,
and I'd been in this stuff way too long,
I'm very angry, sweaty,
and the camera just had to
come around and get my eyes.
And then the movie opens, it's Santa.
These kids again, "He hit me."
"He pinched me."
"Cut.
Guys," and we get them.
15 takes later-
- Oh!
- The kid said one more word
and I let out the loudest F-bomb.
- Oh no! (laughs)
- And I turned around and
there are 12 children,
looked like that you had
ripped their legs off.
Their Santa has just screamed the F-bomb.
- (laughs) Oh my god.
- And quickly, Disney people came in
and calmed the parents down.
He says, "No, what he said was
(speaks in foreign language),
it's a Swedish word.
It sounds like that, but
it's means holiday trim."
And they got into, kids didn't buy it.
- Uh uh, uh uh. (laughs)
- Nobody bought it.
I never did that again.
I realized I shocked these poor kids.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- And it's tough on a pirate.
- That's like, that's
like a movie in itself,
Santa losing his mind on there.
(stammers) That's like
"Bad Santa". (laughs)
It's amazing.
- Well, they've done a whole
bunch of "Bad Santas" actually,
but my character in that
was a kind, wonderful Santa,
and I said, and I'm anything but that.
- [Kelly] (laughs) I love those movies.
I think they're so great.